now there been many critics of the
government's approach to tackling
coronavirus who just heard from one of
them there but few have been more vocal
than the former chief scientific adviser
ser David King he's even set up his own
group of scientists who have called
themselves independent stage to give
some alternative advice actually that
provided by the government's official
committee and Professor King joins us
now thank you for being with us now
you've done an estimate haven't you of
the number of deaths that you fear that
we could see in the next nine months can
you just explain what it is you've been
looking at and what you found well thank
you so Pete let me start if I may by
saying into the previous discussion
Scotland Ireland and Northern Ireland
are successfully nearing zero kovat and
that is what we're calling for now that
the that Britain as a whole should
demand zero kovat UK now what what does
that mean what we're saying is 27,000
excess deaths are likely between now and
next April if the expectation by the
chief medical officer that he would be
surprised and delighted if the UK's in
the same place next spring if he's
correct then we would still have about
two to three thousand new infections in
England per day and that is the number
of deaths that would follow from that
now quite clearly what independent stage
is calling for is first of all this is
an almost entirely preventable and unab
solutely unacceptable it's immoral but
let me also add in response to your
question to the previous speaker it is
best for economic recovery the quicker
we can get bit down to zero kovat UK the
more quickly we can get a full economic
opening of our economies right across
the United Kingdom it looks as if the
policy is to maintain the current level
of about three thousand new infections a
day across England while Scotland I know
Island and northern are they are heading
towards zero net
and of course it just seems to me very
self-evident that is the right policy
let me go say if we take the last three
to four weeks when we began to soften
the lockdown and talk about it and we
saw that the rate of infection pooling
was actually then slowing down and now
it's stopped over the last two or three
weeks now over that period if the
disease had been spreading at roughly
how every five or six days this would
mean that we would have achieved having
from 3,000 to 1500 in the first week to
750 in the second week to 375 in the
third week that is the normal means of
getting a an epidemic under control
and at that point we have the ability to
test every single new okay I'm gonna try
and button with a question here if you
forgive me for that
and you're talking about a zero coded
target but I'm interested to know how
exactly is that achieved because of
course we'd all like to see zero covert
but it clearly would mean a pretty
strenuous and significant lockdown and
you were saying there that actually
there's an economic benefit to
preventing a second way which of course
I accept but you know I've just been to
Birmingham this week talking to a
theater where she said 70% of theaters
for example facing insolvency by
Christmas job redundancies coming out
now there is and I come on it cost to
not lifting look down now as well as in
there surely you will accept that
of course I accept that but of course
part of that is going to be driven
through by government policies to reduce
the furlough scheme and so on so let me
say at once independent state is very
sensitive to all of these issues we
believe that we ought to look at
returning to school as a priority and
then creating safe mechanisms for doing
this perhaps requisitioning
requisitioning playgrounds whatever we
need much more out-of-the-box thinking
on dealing with priorities I fully
understand publicans who would like to
be getting back to to full operation but
I would also advise
is anybody publicans included only open
up that area of your pub where people
can be outdoors and serve people
outdoors so they're not rushing into
each other going into the pub there are
means of achieving these objectives but
they have we have to be patient and if
we're not patient of course it's not
just a second wave as you're saying
there but if it bumps along at 3,000 a
day that is what produces this
additional 27,000 deaths and we haven't
yet then opened up our economy so we if
we want to return to full economic
growth as quickly as possible get rid of
the COBIT virus and pretty sobering the
idea of all those extra deaths of course
now you clearly feel very strongly that
the UK government is going down the
wrong path I mean you've even feel so
strongly about it that you've set up a
rival advisory body to give alternative
advice so do you think that the
scientific advice is wrong that the
government are getting or do you think
they're just ignoring it and as a result
I guess who should resign I don't think
there's any difference between the
scientists on Sage and the scientists on
independence age I think the difference
is that we are in the public domain
you're talking to me and not to the
chair people of Sage precisely because
they're not free to come and be
cross-examined by the media and and
frankly that is the way to gain the
trust of the public in the policies that
the government wants to lay down the
whole issue is extraordinary challenging
and by the way we're not providing an
alternative to Sage what we're doing is
providing an independent voice for the
public and the government to listen to
in this mechanism when I was chief side
advisor whenever I could I was out in
the public domain explaining my advice
to government and then explaining that
it was government that made the policy
and made the decisions I think just to
come in at the same time they're just to
come in there is a divergence of views
among scientists I spoke to for example
some art wall port on the show very
recently who was making the point that
the government needs to try and weigh up
the
economics as well as the virus infection
rate and that broadly speaking he
understood the policy decisions that
they were making well I only know that I
simply don't understand what sir mark is
saying there are we saying that this is
the reason why we went into lockdown so
late much later than every other country
but during a period when the disease was
doubling every three to four days in
this country if we've gone into lockdown
just a week earlier we already would
have had a much better chance to get out
of the pandemic and we also by the way
would have had a quarter of the number
of deaths we've had so I completely
agree with him we need to look at the
fastest route out of Kobe 19 and that is
not the point and the and that it means
a better economic recovery as well it's
just not right I'm just gonna squeeze in
one final question that we are out of
time and sort of appreciate a brief
answer if you could and the impact was
talking about the possibility of
stopping people from England or Wales
traveling to Scotland without a
quarantine potentially if the infection
rates continue to be lower in Scotland
would that be a good idea I think that
the whole question is a disastrous
follow-through from the failure of the
English policy to do the same as the
Scottish and the Northern Ireland and
Ireland for that matter we we are all an
island nation together we're not using
that as our mechanism for controlling we
should be the government discussing this
with the heads of the other nations
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning it's much
appreciated thank you